dressed for a date with destiny saying
terry arrives outside phnom penh's
municipal court
the human rights activist and lawyer is
wearing the dress she wore to the opera
with the number nine inked on her arm
the date when cambodia's opposition
leader was due to return from exile
and they took this image from my
facebook
and they said that this is evidence that
i have committed treason that i have
committed incitement to social disorder
but the opposition leader sam rainsy
never returned
instead 130 government critics were
arrested and now face 12 years in prison
head shaved ready for jail she tells us
she's not afraid she survived the khmer
rouge prison camp as a child and she
sees disturbing similarities today
without exaggeration cambodia currently
is a prison without walls the same way
that during the khmer rouge years
cambodia was a prison
all of it was a prison without walls
current prime minister hun sen served as
a commander in the khmer rouge military
leadership in the 1970s
he defected to vietnam before that
country invaded cambodia in 1979
overthrowing the khmer rouge and
installing a puppet government that
hunsen led in 1985.
he's been in power ever since in what
many fear is now a one-party state
and it's not just the political
opposition who are being shut down the
government's being increasingly strict
on workers who are trying to protest
their conditions arresting and closing
them down with the security services
the demonstrations have attracted
international attention but united
nations observers are bustled out of the
area by the police
behind the cover of a bus the protesters
are put on board and taken out of the
area
they face detention and fines for what
the government says are violations
against covert 19 measures
their cries ignored as journalists are
hustled out of the way
and the only major opposition leader who
hasn't fled into exile is also under the
threat of jail
normally everyone knows what the
cambodian court is like i do not need to
comment but it depends on the repressive
atmosphere if the political environment
works well i believe the court will make
a good decision
as he heads to court also charged with
treason that might be optimistic
with his party banned his colleagues
exiled and hundreds of his supporters
jailed defiance looks like a lonely
stand tony chang al-jazeera phnom penh